okay so you want to do now paul i have
some not politics so if you wanna do
some not politic stuff
um cause i'm gonna have something
for that nothing more than non-political
stuff
all right what about remember this guy
we covered him
before tusk the the uh the pickup artist
wait so he's basically like just david
bond except he can grow facial hair
right he's
he's dave he's david bond but with only
23 000 subscribers
so um the title of this you want to talk
about a scumbag by this guy
this guy may be a bigger scumbag than
david bond okay
that's a high bar i'm not doubting you
i'm just saying that is you're setting
up a high [ __ ] bar here so i'm going
to read the title you ready okay
girl has boyfriend but likes me then
he shows up ready he's setting up
hitting cameras as he hits on girls
ready here you go i walked past her she
gave me a super strong look
and me and egg were kind of standing
around being like [ __ ] because as i
walked past her she gave me a super
strong look like
blatant staring ioi okay so this is him
this is him hitting on her and this is
his buddy recording it by the way people
describing their interactions with women
always kind of remind me of like middle
school kids like
because like when you get to be an adult
you sort of learn that nobody really
gives a [ __ ]
about how good you do with chicks like
that's that's a k it
it's it's very childlike to me when
they're like and then she was all like
she was looking at me right and i was
like yeah dude she definitely likes me
so like i went up to her right
like as you get older guys know that
other guys really don't give a [ __ ]
about these stories
who's her boyfriend kenny omega that was
your boyfriend
so this is by the way guys notice that
hot broad that's on the [ __ ]
logo because he gets chicks that that
that [ __ ] that
logo belongs on a sticker on a truck in
a walmart parking lot or a nascar event
so really interesting beach approach
from tulum
for you today as with my replacement
cameraman egg
we put a secret santa present in les's
stocking
filled his christmas stack up with
that's right we got ourselves a
christmas stocking full of [ __ ]
we've just been coming in this christmas
sock and for a year he's going to love
it
it's going to be his favorite gift a
particular spy cam that we've been
playing around with these fourth
conversations my girls
are going to be they're going to look
[ __ ] cool because the camera is small
we're not going to tell you which camera
is but it's a small kind of spy cam mask
if you come on training with us or if
you work with us
did he says if you come on training with
us
so like he does like training retreats
look all these guys do they all have a
program
they all have something like all these
like
online like program guys they all have
like a thing that you pay and you come
hang out with us and we teach you the
uh-huh seek remember cernovich wanted to
do that for a while he wanted to do the
gorilla club
gorilla mining and he wouldn't take no
for an answer but it's like serious no
but seriously like
that's that's the new thing is the
[ __ ] um
is pain making people pay to hang out
with you because like the whole thing is
this guy's target demo are already
[ __ ]
socially awkward losers so they'll
obviously pay to learn how to not be
socially awkward losers
and it's like uh the old rainmaker
approach i mean you pay this guy to make
it rain and if it rains he takes credit
and if it doesn't rain he finds ways to
get you to pay but
also when it's like when it's like a
good-looking dude with a british accent
like
that's probably that's 99 of the reason
that it's working for you buddy
you know if if it was somebody that
looked like e frog
you know he's not going to be [ __ ]
did this program's not going to work for
him or they have
money which doesn't hurt either and a
lot of these guys that don't like they
have no confidence they have no money
they have no they've none of the things
that are going to get them women anyway
so then you'd go i'll teach you the
secrets and it's like
the secret's easy don't give this guy
[ __ ] three grand
save your money invest it make more
money get a good job and women will [ __ ]
you eventually
and can we just keep saying can i just
point out that they keep bringing up spy
cams
and look no adult male
uh can talk about spy cans and not be
creepy unless that man's name is sal
volcano
that's the only time it's not weird what
if it's like behind a big clock
while you're counting your drug money
but it's like what but it's a very
obvious clock it's very obvious a giant
hole
right and nobody notices it it literally
says kodak on the clock correct
they're gonna be they're gonna look
[ __ ] cool because the camera is small
we're not going to tell you which camera
is but it's a small kind of spy cam mask
if you come on training with us or if
you work with us we're going to actually
film some of your approaches with it
also in bars you're going to see some
approaches oh man george
[ __ ] figured out here's the secret
women like hot guys
better than rich guys just crazy
approaches because it's so discreet
it depends on the woman i think right i
think it depends yeah yeah
i i don't listen let me tell you
something women will cheat on the rich
guy with a hot guy
but women will not leave the rich guy
for a hot guy
i'm sorry i don't give a [ __ ] who you
are they might have some dude with abs
that sleeps on a mattress on the floor
that they [ __ ]
on the side but when that young guy goes
i want you to leave your husband for me
that chick's gonna like sit down and do
the math and go
yeah no i already have a rich husband
and i'm already cheating on him so i
kind of have the best of both worlds
here
well what the hell it is we without
further ado we were walking on the beach
in tulum
the i gave a brief intro to this video
but
me and uh again the assistant cameraman
we were [ __ ] around with the audio so
we hadn't worked out that you need to
hold it right close your face on the
wireless mic
hence why actually going to overlay this
onto a clip you see the girl in the top
left
she was sitting to set the scene on a
sunbed with another with two other guys
cuddled up with one guy with tattoos um
and me and egge were kind of standing
around being like [ __ ] because
as i walked past her she gave me a super
strong look like
blatant staring ioi indicator of
interest
showing stupid do you see what i mean
this sounds like a middle school right
this is not
like women would you say that women
being interested in you
shouldn't be an event like it's not a
story-worthy event
when you're in your early 20s maybe
you'll go like
dude i picked up this chick the other
day like bro she was
i [ __ ] me and i was like i knew i was
it but you i'm telling you those the
the in the incidence of those stories
drops off when you get older because
it's not an interesting
topic like guys don't like this thing of
like
like locker room talk obviously get some
drinks you might go down that road yeah
somebody might start talking about it
and you might start telling stories but
like
this feels very right does this not feel
very like middle school
and then she was like totally looking at
me bro like she was like we made eye
contact and i knew
that she wanted me yo so like i knew so
like i started working my program on it
and it's like oh god you sound like
those kids in middle school
that just were like i think she likes me
dude and you go
okay then go talk to like what do you
care what do i care
so it required a bit of calibration so
we kind of waited out looking like we
were looking into the sea
just chilling relaxing at some point she
actually gets up and you can see her
walk into the ocean
in the back of this shot which this this
audio is going to be overlaid onto
and then what she actually did was walk
back into the hotel
so they were lying on some beds and
there was a hotel behind she walked back
into the hotel
a gay was like [ __ ] man she's probably
going to the bar that's the time to
capitalize and so we were like yeah okay
let's do it
so we walked into the hotel everything
is listen every capital i i just the
everything is transactional with these
people
everything we did this david bond has
this whole program with his bots and is
figuring out how to scam uh dating sites
and stuff
everything is a program every [ __ ]
every dinner every interaction with
people is
transactional these people are
sociopaths it's
it i understand
yes because it's true again i know i get
it but it's just it's just
there's no like there's no look there's
nothing wrong with
learning certain tricks of the trade
there's nothing um
by the way somebody said mercy is just
jelly he can't trick women into sex
uh how do you think i've ever had sex
yeah what are you talking about yeah
literally every woman that's ever [ __ ]
me has been tricked on some level
either into thinking that i have more
money than i do thinking i'm not a
narcissist whatever the case is drink
wasn't
yeah exactly whatever the case is that
tricked a lot of people
i'm basically like loki but with a dick
um
loki has a dick have you seen it no i
so there you go should i have seen it um
tom hiddleston does not
look like a man with a dick okay so um
fair enough the point being that these
people the straw man argument by the way
i'm [ __ ] kidding you in your whole
family um but everything is like with
these people they're sociopathic they
can't look at anything through the lens
of
just a genuine engagement now is there
is there is there is nothing wrong with
that as i said you you
learn a couple of things maybe you learn
some things that that help you
in dealing with people socially
there's nothing wrong with learning a
couple of uh for instance uh there's
books you can read on um
body language and things like that
there's there's books you can read on
uh communication that aren't by the way
a program it's not like
say a b or c and then you will have
chicks it's it's more like a project
confidence make eye contact you know
what i mean like things like that
that you can learn that will help you
but that's if you're a human being and
you're trying to
interact with other human beings guys
like this everything is transactional
everything is a give and a take
everything is a business thing it's it's
it's psychotic frankly
he's he's speaking spanish to her
his spanish is
horrendous this guy spanish is
like the way merce would speak spanish
uh perro
uh yeah yeah it's really bad
uh uh uh biblioteca
yeah thank you you said but the library
yeah in what context would you use that
um
i was in a uh i was in a meeting in the
mexican parliament
and they were talking about slashing um
the infrastructure budget
which was going to lead to closures and
i said
um biblioteca well i also would have
accepted
the library i would have also accepted
why are you [ __ ] on the floor
but the library is over there that's a
good that would also work
but no you were asking i can't believe
you'd asked me but the library how would
that ever make sense when we just spent
an entire year in this country listening
to people go
but the post office right it's the same
thing
slashing it getting rid of it just don't
even read books this is crazy
i don't read books either i thought our
books were in english
and you know she's thinking the same
thing like this guy's spanish is
terrible
[Laughter]
also the other thing that i guarantee
you that he does by the way she got some
big feet
but the one thing that i guarantee that
that he does too
is body language he probably has a whole
seminar on body language yeah
which again can help people who are but
because look at his [ __ ] leg how it's
up like he's uh project confidence
and make sure you move into their space
so they know you're an alpha
i guarantee you you read books like that
but the thing is like there's nothing
wrong if you're one of these like
people that or is really bad at it it
actually no i would say if you probably
like that
don't read those books because you'll
actually overdo it and it'll you'll look
ridiculous
and when they say you got a negative and
you're overly aggressive hey you stupid
fat oh [ __ ] you caught you you went on a
date you [ __ ] up and you know what
girls love
ultimatums just give them an ultimatum
right now
by the way they start thinking that that
also applies to
like non-relationship situations hey mom
i want to get the new xbox for christmas
you [ __ ] fat
and she's like god what are you doing
and what what i
said it was first off you're 37 and i'm
in a retirement home
what are you why are you in here you're
embarrassing me hey mom you [ __ ]
divorced
i wanted to get the xbox this year you
[ __ ]
at your father's funeral when you go
shopping i said i wanted
regular [ __ ] i wanted raisin brain
crunch you
[ __ ] you demented
[Laughter]
either that or they read books and
they're like make sure to always make
eye contact so they're like
hi how are you i'm derek would you like
to go out sometime
and it's like jesus dude not that much
eye contact
jesus [ __ ] christ i just need you to
sign for this amazon package i just
really thought maybe we would go out
sometime and she's like why are you
doing that
always always make definitely always
make eye contact
con eye contact project confidence and
she's like why are you talking to
yourself
by the way what he was saying in spanish
was that they're there for a couple
weeks on vacation it just took him a
long time to get to it because the
spanish is very bad
you know what sir we wanted to say this
we uh we like a resume
uh obviously at a very high gpa you've
got all the experience we're looking for
all right that's great so uh we'll talk
salary when do i start you [ __ ]
please that doesn't work you're not
supposed to be
you know what would be funny is that
while he's doing this is just to walk up
in
really good spanish to start making fun
of him in front of his face
that that's the alpha mode you walk up
and just and they'll be like right and
just really but sucks fast too so he
can't keep up
he would lose all his coffee he would
turn around and lose all of his
confidence especially if you get her to
giggle
yes if you get her to laugh and then
kind of look at him wait can you take it
and then they go oh no no
[Laughter]
uh
okay so he said that wrong right but he
technically what he said was right but
he said it like the way
if you were reading it from a spanish
book uh
what he what he wanted to say what he
was trying to say was later do you want
to go get a drink with me
but what he actually said if you were
direct if you were saying it in english
the way he said it is
which means later want drink if i like
later want drink it's it's it is i like
drink later with
you that's like spanish sequential one
when you were in the first year of it
and they were just teaching the basics
yeah and the problem is like i don't
understand people that speak spanish
like this because
like the hardest part of learning a
language right is
learning the language like learning the
actual words and the word structure
once you do that just put a little stank
on it so you don't sound like a
ah royce espanol no estan bueno compinga
shut up
i don't like that that was mean
okay
i hate to say what he meant to say was
used you're darker than me but what he
said is
you are mas moreno you're black
you're blacker than me like you're
blacker than me
this guy is not good at this i hate his
shorts
[Music]
she works at a hotel is what she said
she works at that one and she's probably
like sir i have to get back to work okay
i'm the
i'm the general manager here but like
these guys all do this we've pointed it
out before but they always
they project this life to you of like
i'm living the life
like i got [ __ ] i got all this [ __ ] i
got money but they're always in thailand
or mexico or somewhere where there's
like
where you have an economic advantage
where you have all these advantages so
like yeah you can make it look like
you're the [ __ ] but really you're just
preying on women in third and second
world countries
dancer in the club club
by lotter in the club so he said the
dancing part but then he said in the
club
by the way jj don't use google translate
your [ __ ]
he keeps hitting the mic um
yeah so she works at the reservation
desk at a hotel
ah go shorty
en la complianos go shorty
yeah she's not cute
um so i guess she got the numbers muted
because she was giving the number
tienes your parents agree no
yes nathan nathan by lauren a club
she has only enough accent for it to be
hot but not so much accent that you're
like all right now you sound like that
from modern family yeah sofia vergara oh
god
she's so hot but she goes down like two
points because whether or not
she's like she's like a french dress
shirt yeah exactly exactly yes
yep fran drescher could get it too okay
so give him a kiss and this is the
boyfriend coming up
hangman adam page about to come in and
do a run-in
oh boy
super interesting approach i just did
with the girl on the beach so me and me
and egay walked past we saw a cute girl
with a guy lying all over this guy on
the beach with another guy beside
but i was switched on enough to be
looking and she
[ __ ] basically i [ __ ] the [ __ ] at
me all right so i've seen this couple
they was laying on a beach right
but like i right having absolutely no
respect for people or
social boundaries or really have any
sort of
uh consideration for others uh despite
the fact that these people were clearly
there together
in a romantic sense i decided to uh oh
so this isn't my country of origin
so on top of that he goes to somebody
else's country and does this he's a
garbage person like
not uncommon for guy girls with
boyfriends to do that
but the link the blatancy and length of
which she did it was i was thinking
right this
can't be a serious relationship the
guy's probably sleeping with her i mean
they were probably they were pretty
close together but maybe it's just an
open gig or whatever so i don't know
anyway we sculpt around looking [ __ ]
stupid drawing complete attention to
ourselves
then went back walked back walked into
the bar to see what was going back on
does anybody else want to see this guy
[ __ ] leave the resort grounds and get
because the moment this is this is the
kind of guy that the moment he leaves
the little resort ground in the his
in the whatever [ __ ] whether in
mexico wherever he's at the moment they
leave the resort ground he would get
no i was actually hoping that he goes so
blatant and so far that he hits on some
cartel lieutenants like girlfriend
because they won't even lately yeah they
won't even wait for you to leave them
in the resort came back out
um and at that point the girl had
actually disappeared
i we thought she walked into the bar so
we followed her down
i kind of hesitated when she was at the
sea to approach i was going to kind of
wave at her but i was thinking if the
guy sees he's going to get pissed off
blah blah
anyway so she went she went down to what
we thought was the bar so me and egge
went into the hotel
turns out she actually went to the
bathroom so i mean technically a
terrible
kind of weird approach in the sense i
basically followed her to the bathroom
and she even
pulled out she was like did you follow
me to the bar you followed this woman to
the bathroom i'm telling you it's a real
chad move to follow strange women in
strange countries to the bathroom
she's really like super i'm sorry ladies
in the chat all three of you
do you enjoy being followed to the
bathroom regardless of how good looking
the guy is by the way
would you want to be followed to the
bathroom ladies before you answer
understand that uh
you're only your only options are uh a
yes
and b no yeah pick one
pick one you did oh you don't like
you're over negging again you're over
negging you're
letting me follow you you [ __ ] rug
munching
overnight you're over [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you must not like men if you don't want
this [ __ ] prime cut of meat
why are you over negging again you're
doing it again
a [ __ ] is supposed to be like playful
banter not call him
you think he's so good he gets too good
for me mike i got to ask you what's your
success rate with that tactic
uh zero oh zero okay but you know it's
fine i finally got a bmw
i'm i'm securing some guns oh [ __ ] and
uh i'm thinking of taking a vacation in
uh isla vista
it's going to be a very nice summer i
think this year
now that's a channel you know what i'm
honest i'm going to show every one of
these [ __ ] stuck up little
these little plots i'll [ __ ] show
them
they don't want to be with a gentleman
like myself
you need to do that you actually need to
do a pickup channel a separate pickup
channel
but deadly oh yes just overly aggressive
and
take all of that but go way too far but
go
way too far with them to be honest like
i could probably find no they were
getting married but the girl was i
[ __ ] me so at the wedding
i i would do that as a sketch but i'd
have to
the women would have to be in on it
because kind of [ __ ] the kind of [ __ ]
i would say would get me killed for the
bit and i don't want it but i could
probably find some cute chicks
i'm sure they'll do it yeah you think
you should do this pick up there
like hey what's up so you're looking a
little chunky eh
it's just a piece of [ __ ] yeah and then
you pinch the little
like everybody pinch the little love
handles what's this what do you got
going on there
anyways what's up you want to grab a
drink you're like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
there you go you got a little something
there a little something peeking out
[Music]
somebody has a name for the channel
night straw
what do you think and then every every
video should be like
how to get a woman right and i just keep
going up to women and blowing it and
blowing it and blowing it and blowing it
and as they're walking away i'm like
i have and then you would get them and
then the next it'll just cut to me
sitting with the chick on the beach
somewhere like
so anyway that is chapter one on how to
uh
secure the women you want every single
video ends with
wait hang on hang on hang on i i have
money
it just turns around all right i guess
yeah
all right all right